josée legault michel c'est au jai alai
question gay bonsoir à vous trois
bonsoir
je dois je prends l'exemple de mona
nemer en partant pour lancer le panel
scientifique en chef du canada qui dit
fort avoir
certaine façon qu'on a entre autres les
tests dans les aéroports et tout ça
parce que là on peut se demander si
coûts-bénéfices on devient port ça ne
vient pas déséquilibrer est-ce que c'est
pas là un exemple tour de table où il
faut même si on pense faire le bien il
faut des fois revoir le bien parce que
le bien peut devenir exagéré josé
mais c'est difficile de se prononcer
quand même sur cette question là parce
que ça soulève beaucoup beaucoup de
possibilités je serai bien à l'aise en
ce moment d'avoir un immunologue écoute
mais bon c'est certain que si on avait
des du dépistage par pcr qui nous
privait dessus des tests rapides qui
nous peuvent être vus s'il n'y avait pas
de contagion communautaire si c'est tout
ce qu'avance montané maire finalement
c'est que nous avons tous ces choses là
dedans nous avons pénurie de tests pcr
pénurie de tests rapides et jean nous
avons une communauté déjà communautaire
important qu'est ce qu'on doit vraiment
investir autant de ressources dans les
aéroports une fois que de toute manière
le micro circule partout mais la
question la question se pose la réponse
je n'ai pas
la question se pose c'est une fois qu'il
est entré puis bel et bien en train qui
se propage partout dans la communauté
mais châssis roger qu'est ce que ça vous
inspire quand même
moi je suis pas partisan de laisser
tomber les mesures c'est le père à ce
moment ci mais pour pas faire double
emploi tout le temps non plus pour
rentrer dans l'avion fort à propos de
données
de test négatif c'est quand même assez
rare que ça se développe pendant trois
heures d'avion chauds ou maraudes ont
des seins alors il ya des choses qui
sont pas utiles ou qui ont utilisé très
faible
cette démarche là en plus de dire encore
une fois parce que quand il un problème
qui arrivera à venir de l'étranger de
repos hydro de transmission
communautaire et sylvain nadeau alors je
trouve que dans chocolat c'est pas de
ses plus de 600 m alec
il est tellement d'incohérences dans la
gestion de la frontière on est est
toujours poste qui arrivent par avion
des états unis alors que senna est le
plus gros partenaire plus importante de
tests que ceux qui viennent de
l'étranger alors qu au micro l'un des
endroits où il se propage de plus
pourquoi on teste avant d'embarquer dans
l'avion et on doit re tester ensuite
alors qu'on a une pénurie de tests pcr
mais surtout qu'on a fait 330 mille
tests depuis qu'on a instauré cette
mesure lot de test à la frontière y en a
un pour cent qui sont revenus positifs
de ces tests le 1 % de gens qui sont
probablement très asymptomatiques parce
que lyon joue redoublement vacciner
parce que pour 1% de gens qui arrivent
ici qui arrive dans une transmission
communautaire déjà très forte de micron
ça vaut un demi milliard les retards
pour les gens qui doivent attendre le
résultat de leurs tests à la maison
parce que certaines obligatoires comme
les résultats sont tellement lent à
arriver dans le respect s'est fait jour
à la maison c'est peut-être jours c'est
plus que le cinq jours on a deux
maintenant dans la plupart des provinces
il ya beaucoup beaucoup de politiques
autour de la frontière et ça commence à
faire un petit peu un petit peu bizarre
location soit à ce point les sites côté
là du côté du gouvernement fédéral
très bien ce qui m'amène ou l autre
sujet le questionnement que les gens ont
au québec quand il voit les mesures et
michel j'avais dit quelque chose
d'important jeudi je ne crois pas que
c'est le moment d'assouplir les règles
sanitaires actuellement or je vous
montre juste un petit tableau
aujourd'hui les hospitalisations danser
les soins intensifs qui est devenu le
marqueur par excellence québec 33 par un
million d'habitants plus que la moyenne
canadienne
états unis beaucoup plus 77 mais le
québec est plus qu'un moyenne canadienne
des soins intensifs sur le goût hier à
tout et il y en a moins qu en ontario
mais il ya une question de population
bref
ma question
est ce que les gens sont pas en droit de
se dire comment ça se fait qu'on a
depuis le début les mesures les plus
strictes au québec et que les résultats
son choix comparable soit plus mauvais
qu'ailleurs josé
mais oui c'était questionnement légitime
mais en même temps on peut comprendre
sur le couvre-feu parce que le retour de
ce couvre-feu le in extremis de lutte à
mal le jour de la il était
incompréhensible et s'il avait été si
efficace que ça premièrement on n'aurait
pas une version pire que le reste du
canada et deuxième halle le premier
ministre répond ah non aussi qu'ils
l'annulent est à partir de ce soir donc
ça c'est ça c'est une erreur et je pense
que ça discute maintenant pour le reste
je suis je suis assez d'accord avec
michel c je pense que là on est encore
dans le principe de précaution et des
quelle mesure par le ton à l'effet le
port du masque vient en réalité de
nombreux et en maintenant les
spécialistes recommandent même de porter
des masques de type n 95 parce que
utilisent les chirurgiens comme le
disait le premier ministre bayer
des masques beaucoup plus efficace que
les basques médicaux qui sont
disponibles en vente libre est ce qu'on
parle de ventilation dont on ne sait que
toujours pour beaucoup au québec parce
que on lit le gouvernement hésite à
reconnaître que la transmission
dominante et par aérosol et cetera moi
je pense qu'on devrait même accentuer
ses mesures la plus qu'autre chose
michel
on est on est en droit de se poser des
questions et qui quelle est la variable
qui est par la berd dans toutes les
provinces canadiennes c'est l'état
justiciable de santé du système
auxiliaire particulier auprès de quatre
artères bouchées doubles ben oui quand
on a enfin monsieur dubé dire
cinquante mille personnes dans le
système de santé ana ortiz et 70 villes
écoutez c'est du monde et notre collègue
de refaire la gazette celui qu'elle veut
et au jour des soirées d'aller pas qui
fait sous la longue série de tweets les
fêtes semaine disait bta départ ville et
aux jeunes
les hôpitaux ils vont vous dire si les
fermiers est responsable de deux fois
plus de patients que devrait avoir comme
charges qui a eu une urgence à quelque
part va le repos le temps de s'occuper
de deuxième urgence à votre choix alors
peut-être que la réponse pourquoi
l'ontario vaut mieux que le québec mais
pourquoi de choses
arrivent c'est le fait que le système
est vraiment à l'accord les est sur le
point de rupture depuis le début cette
fois ci je ne sais pas si actuellement
l'ontario va mieux que le québec mais on
peut pas dire il ya beaucoup de morts qu
on vous ouvre l autre débat ouvert le
1er mai 110 non les calculs différemment
long l'euro la réponse en six mois vous
y croyez pas sa mission chaud
voilà voilà même et si je peux
rapidement c'est que
sékou sylla où on a moins bien fait ici
c'est justement la question de la
ventilation dans les écoles en ontario
on a ôté beaucoup plus proactif sur la
question encore une fois des masques de
type n 95 on est plus proactifs dans
certaines zones des provinces dont
l'ontario mais ici
mais qu'est ce que vous voulez la santé
publique et le premier ministe 10 aux
québécois que c'est plus efficace que
les masques médicaux alors que les
experts des exactement où on serre
entrent en jeu ouvrait toutes sauvées
par atteint mais sur les masques jsp qu
indique le masque de procédure était
aussi josé efficace que le n95 dans un
milieu d'une classe
mais j'ai sculpté moi je ne parle pas au
nom des experts qui sort et dépendant du
gouvernement ouais mais consulter et
puis regardez toutes les études
scientifiques qui sortent depuis
quelques semaines séparent et salah à
travers le monde et tout ce monde là
d'une contraire donc
avec excusez moi
dans le sujet de la discussion est-ce
que malgré nos mesures plus strictes
qu'ailleurs c'est un fait quand même les
gens qui voyagent un peu le voyeur josé
vous dis quelle mesure restaurant par
exemple passeport vaccinale pour entrer
dans les grandes surfaces pour rallier à
la sécu etc c'est plus sévère ici
qu'ailleurs or on ne voit pas
nécessairement les bénéfices à l'aide de
sa de cette sévérité la
fin ce n'est pas avec qui vous comparez
le par rapport à l'ontario qui a à peu
près les mêmes mesures que nous
maintenant que le couvre-feu et enlever
la 1re grosso modo en ontario c'est pas
mal pareil les salles de restauration
fermé les salles de spectacles aussi le
nouveau brunswick et les mêmes mesures
au québec donc au canada la colombie
britannique ou encore des restaurants
ouverts le met à bien des endroits ça se
ressemble aux etats unis c'est une autre
mentalité je pensais que la comparaison
vaut la peine qu en europe effectivement
le commencer à gérer sont un peu
différemment je pense qu'on voudrait
bien aussi apprendre à vivre avec le
virus au québec notre système de santé
n'était pas aussi fragile on ne pourrait
donner un petit peu plus d'exiger une
méthode qu'on est encore à plus de 3300
hospitalisation on nous vend les écoles
on a enlevé couvre-feu je pense qu'on ne
peut pas aller plus loin du côté du
gouvernement avant au moins de trois
semaines le savoir à quoi vont
ressembler les l'épidémiologie qui vont
aussi bien effectivement on peut donner
un peu plus d'oxygène parce qu'il faut
pour que ça vaille dans les hôpitaux où
l'on peut pas rester à un niveau de
délestage comme celui là commence à
ouvrir d'autres pans de la société qu'on
le veuille ou pas la réalité c'est les
hôpitaux la très bien comme une
résultante je veux parler de bourget ok
on va on a le temps marguerite blais un
petit mot la tutelle vendredi joseph
j'avais écouté je crois le témoignage
devant la coronaire madame blais jouffa
entendre le petit extrait c'est au
sortir le son témoignage dans les côtes
l'enquêté de la coroner
c'est une enquête importante
je veux remercier madame la coroner cas
mais elle parce que
avec son enquête qui est finalement
public
ça va faire en sorte qu'on va changer la
façon dont on prend soin de nous
personne archives je vous rappelle
marguerite blais qui est en congé de
maladie
quittant repos donc ils venus témoigner
devant la connaître josé qu'est ce que
vous avez retenu neuf la manchette ça a
été encore de quelques contradictions
entre des mines et sur le moment où on
est vraiment intervenus dans les sachets
celle des caisses qui vous avez retenu
vous
j'ai trouvé ça plus bizarre qu'on compte
titres ça parce que lorsqu'on parle
d'éliminer la santé daniel maghen dans
la soie route de alex souligny
soutiendront la santé qui avaient dit
qu'ils ont affirmé leur enlevant la
coronaire que il avait averti les pdg
des cieux cédé 6 dès la fin janvier de
préparer les ch et celle d or tout ce
qui a été soumis jusqu'à demain inclus à
ce que la ministre blais audi pas tout
au long de son témoignage est allé fait
très solide et alité documenté est
exactement le contraire c'est une
contradiction mais c'est une
contradiction face à une version qui
n'était pas crédible et qu'ils avaient
été dénoncés par tout aussi en même
temps donc moi j'ai trouvé encore un
poil à la minute je les trouvais solide
et ce qu'elle a dit en sortant est très
très important parce que ça reflète
aussi ce que la coronaire kamel lui
jodie en toute fin d'audience c'est que
son travail à gm canada c'était de
trouver ce qui s'était passé pour
améliorer les choses à la mairie madame
l'ampli est quelque chose de très
important à la fin je suppose a été
retenu ailleurs mais elle dit il le
faudra pour que ce peuple est visible
parce que c'est comme ça qu'elle appelle
non seulement les aînés mais toutes les
personnes vulnérables au québec pour que
ce peuple invisible
deviennent peut-être celui que joueront
un rôle plus alors c'est c'est très
important et j'ai trouvé la chimie aussi
entre la coroner et la ministre il y
avait une bonne chimie
on voyait que la coroner kamel avait
beaucoup de respect pour la ministre
blais d'ailleurs elle leur remercié à la
fin du viol demandé de conserver ses
valeurs humaines elle a pas dit ça à
tout le monde on a vu qu'aujourd'hui ça
a été le contraire d'un gt mariage où
elle ne l était pas mal exaspéré par ce
que l es pas capable d'avoir des
versions crédible mais je pense que
vendredi elle a eu une version critique
très bien un petit mot là-dessus alec et
michel allex
mais en fait maguette blais à confirmer
ce qu'on savait déjà parce que la
protectrice du citoyen avait fait déjà
enquête et que son rapport était
derrière moi j'avais plus chez toutes
les toutes les procès verbaux 10 et
brand content du ministère de la santé
en janvier-février jamais il y avait été
mention dès 6 h et celle dés lors de ces
rencontres là beaucoup de témoins ont
dit qu'effectivement avant la fin mars
début avril ce n'était pas sur les
travailleurs du ministère de la santé le
siège de selb est la seule personne en
fait qui a été trop loin dans son
témoignage ces derniers le méthane
lorsqu'elle a dit qu'elle envoie une
note disant on paie des jeux de se
préparer les promotions des ch et ses
listes une note extrêmement vague qui
fait ses schémas régionaux que tous les
arômes boisés
là pour donner aux plus vulnérables sont
en danger fait quelque chose d'honnête
massot
révisionnisme historique alors
marguerite blais tout simplement
confirmer ce qu'on savait déjà est ce
que le gouvernement lui même admis à
plusieurs reprises on s'y est pris trop
tard je ne comprends pas pourquoi il est
encore une version qui circule celle de
madame mais cannes c'est le divan
gendron l'ancien sous-ministre zaouaoui
on avait dit à tout le monde de se
préparer peut-être qu'on avait du
sauvage main mais beaucoup trop
vaguement pour les chsct en commun
festivement n'était pas prêt une chelsea
sur l'autre sujet je vous relance
bspp par st pierre plamondon dans
bourget sur l'île de montréal est ce un
choix stratégiquement intéressant selon
vous
où il ses choix stratégiques
m'intéressant d'abord c'est un côté
historique pour le pq je veux d'ailleurs
cerclé cas mais il aurait lorsque
l'élection va être déclenchée c'est une
tête c'est une lutte à trois entre le
député sortant de la caq le pq et québec
solidaire si on regarde les résultats de
la dernière élection et dans une lutte à
trois 1 le chef de parti va être
avantagé beaucoup plus de visibilité que
les autres bien plus bouger ses bons
real donc s'il faut réagir une crise ou
quoi que ce soit on est plus souvent à
montréal ces peluches pas facile venez
vous vous donner notre put patrice que
quand on est en train de le dessin de
donner au lac saint jean ont dévoyé dans
le parc
josé un petit mot là dessus
oui moi j'suis d'accord avec avec michel
c écoutez c'est sûr que pour le parti
québécois ils sont chers et il n'ya pas
ne plus vraiment de
pascal
ben voilà c'est donc il doit risquer
quelque chose et à risque et c'est
peut-être son meilleur pari de rien
garanti mais c'est peut-être moins pire
de tous les ans très bien
et ils savent fort bien
marie-victorin il a décliné marc
therrien d'ailleurs twizz années j'étais
d'accord qui faisait la bonne chose
marie victorin anne casabonne
éric duhaime est allé chercher cette
comédienne qu'on connaît très bien que
les gens québec connaissent très bien
qui est qui avait traité les vaccins
comme étant de la m après dix ans je
faisais de l'ironie je faisais du market
etc bon bref qu'est ce que quoi en
penser à ce que j'aime au fait oui ou
non selon vous politiquement un bon coup
alec
le site est parce qu on a parlé d'éric
duhaime de son parti toute la journée
pascal casabonne de véritables chances
de remporter me marie victorin la
réponse est non j'espère qu'il le sait
le courant conservateur qu'il soit
fédéral ou provincial dans la grande
région de montréal est très faible et ce
conscription où il ya déjà des candidats
intéressants et importants qui vont se
présenter donc ses chances de gagner
sont faibles et mais c'est certain que
ça fait partie de la stratégie de
communication du hem que d'attirer
l'attention en allant chercher claire
samson avait fait la même chose à
l'assemblée nationale maintenant il
faudra aussi deux côtés d'eric zoom par
un peu attention parce qu'on se collent
tellement intime mesures sanitaires aux
anti vaccins dans certains 10 des dicos
que ceux qui sont pour qui croit la
pandémie qui pense qu'on a un rôle
collectif a joué une action utile mais
qui sont de droite économique qui aurait
pu être intéressé par éric duhaime parce
que la caq n'est pas une droite
économique pour tout se demander avec
quel type de personne ils vont sans
qu'aucune ici votre pour ce prix vient
récompenser attention dans la promenade
des choses chez les josé 30 secondes
chacun
c'est exactement ça le problème c'est
que monsieur
je suis jeune et de vielles le porte
parole des outils d'accès le parti des
outils d'accès radio mois d'octobre
peut-être que ça sera plus chaud la
question qui évolue et qui va lui être
rentable et on oublie pour l'instant là
la droite économique qui se cherche
josé
mais moi je pense qu'ils cherchent
surtout à fédérer des gens pas seulement
les archives ac cela mais des gens qui
sont en colère contre le gouvernement le
groupe sévillanes partie de la
population prioritaire j'en conviens
mais qui voient françois legault comme
dangereux socialiste at her qui va
contrôler la vie des québécois c'est ces
gens là qui luisent éric duhaime et
alain cazabonne
on ne connaît pas encore je le disais
plus tôt dans l'émission la date mais
quelque part au printemps quand la neige
fondra il recède partiel dans marie
victorin à nantes elle et pour le
fascicule quand on y reviendra bon damas
merci beaucoup à vous trois au revoir
bonne soirée
pour voir nos émissions en entier rendez
vous sur la chaîne i cirdi
oh